[Musica]
il buio
immaginate di vista
sentite il sole che bacia la vostra
pelle
la sabbia che si muove sotto i nostri
piedi
i nostri
perde nelle mille sfumature di lui
respirate
sentito il profumo della salsedine
della macchia mediterranea è il profumo
di casa del mare nostrum
nostro perché la nostra identità è
plasmata dagli elementi naturali che ci
circondano e perché il mare
inizia da qui
io mi sono innamorata del mare quando
ero una bambina
tre mesi d'estate
a giocare con le onde e con l'acqua
della sardegna sempre a piedi nudi e
sempre con il panino in bocca pur di non
aspettare quelle due ore prima di
rientrare in acqua da pro pranzo il
risultato non è stata un indigestione
ma è stata una carriera dedicata al mare
e capricci infiniti quando tornava a
milano perché non volevo assolutamente
più mettere le scarpe a 15 anni ho
capito veramente che il mare sarebbe
stata parte integrante
della mia vita
galeotti furono le prime immersioni in
cui scoprire un mondo nuovo ei miei
occhi si riempivano di una luce che
ancora brilla alimentata dalla gioia di
scoprire
centinaia di specie diverse sia perché
il mediterraneo il nostro mare un mare è
ricchissimo di biodiversità pensate che
occupa meno dell'un per cento del
pianeta e della superficie ricoperta
dall'oceano
ma è ospita il 10 per cento di tutte le
specie marine
stiamo parlando di 17mila specie un
quarto delle pane è in the mica cioè
vuol dire che vive solo nel mediterraneo
e non bisogna andare troppo
piano per scoprire questa biodiversità
basta guardare certe volte meglio
uno scoglio
l'avete mai vista sono sicuro che avete
visto una patella ma non l'avete degnata
dell'attenzione che merita
questo piccolo animale ci dimostra come
gli animali che vivono su uno scoglio e
in generale nelle cose sono in grado di
sopravvivere a eventi estremi come caldo
torrido d'estate e inverni rigidi
durante i mesi invernali
e questa patella in generale tutte le
patelle curiosi curiosamente si muovono
sempre solo verso sinistra rimangono
ancorate attaccata con lo scoglio
attraverso dei piccoli dentini che per
noi a guardarli sembrano insignificanti
ma in realtà sono il più materiale più
resistente mai scoperto dagli scienziati
sul nostro pianeta
e lasciamo la patella al suo scoglio la
superficie e ci immergiamo abbassare una
decina di metri qualche decina di metri
scopriamo che quello stesso scoglio si
trasforma in una sorella
e un giardino colorato sono le gorgonie
questi coralli mondi dalla forma arbore
scelte che svolgono un ruolo
fondamentale per la salute del
mediterraneo perché tantissime specie
affidano ai loro rami le loro uova per
proteggerne da potenziali predatori e
altre specie come quella che vediamo la
standa corre con e non di rado abitano
sulle loro sul loro braccio e sui loro
rami quindi già in questo piccolo
viaggio da uno scoglio abbiamo scoperto
tre specie ce ne mancano solo 16
1997 per aree alla fine
a parte gli scherzi che cosa vi
ricordano queste forme
cosa vi ricorda vi dà un piccolo indizio
la risposta è un altro animale marino
almeno al nome di un altro animale
marino
e medusa
una delle tre sorelle gorgoni
famose nella cultura mitologica per
essere di estrema bellezza ma anche per
pietrificare chiunque osasse guardando
direttamente negli occhi escluse anche
per avere dei serpenti al posto dei
capelli serpenti che ricordano le forme
della borgogna della stella gorgone ed è
per questo che prendono da loro il nome
dal mito dal mare andiamo al mito e dal
mito possiamo passare alla storia perché
forse non sapete che i fondali oceanici
sono considerati il museo più grande che
esiste sulla nostra terra cioè
contengono così tanti reperti
archeologici e storici che
effettivamente se mettiamo insieme tutti
quelli che abbiamo in tutti i musei
della terraferma
ne abbiamo ancora di meno
il problema è che rischiano di perdere
questo patrimonio archeologico ma anche
quello naturalistico ancora prima di
conoscerlo
abbiamo considerato il mare sempre così
vasto da ritenerlo infinito infinito
nella sua capacità di soddisfare i
nostri bisogni e praticamente immune
all'azione umana
purtroppo non è così siamo riusciti a
cambiare drasticamente il mare e con una
velocità mai immaginata prima
temiamo il mediterraneo purtroppo è uno
dei mari più inquinati che esista al
mondo sulla sua superficie
galleggiano in media 64 milioni di
particelle di micro pasticche per
chilometro quadrato e la maggior parte
della plastica in realtà noi non la
vediamo perché sul fondo delle vere e
proprie discariche a questi si
aggiungono altre tipologie di
inquinamento come ad esempio
l'inquinamento da metalli pesanti ma
anche altre tipologie meno conosciute
come l'inquinamento acustico
purtroppo non è l'unica minaccia per il
nostro mare ci sono anche i cambiamenti
climatici che nell'ambiente marino si
traducono in una acidificazione e di
ossigenazione delle acque e un aumento
della loro temperatura che non
mediterraneo sta avvenendo del 20 per
cento più velocemente rispetto al resto
del mondo questo modo le conseguenze su
ogni forma di vita anche noi pensate
alle ondate di calore pensate
all'innalzamento del livello del mare
che solo nel bacino del mediterraneo e
mette a rischio 20 milioni di persone è
pensata la perdita di biodiversità
alimentata anche adesso verst dal
sovrasfruttamento delle risorse
nel mediterraneo tre parti delle specie
ittiche sono considerate sovrasfruttate
vuol dire che peschiamo più della loro
capacità di riprodursi quindi altro che
immune all'azione umana siamo riusciti
addirittura a cambiare la composizione
chimica fisica del nostro mare
tutti i campanelli d'allarme che in
precedenza sono suonate in occasione
delle grandi estinzioni di massa
non a caso negli ultimi 50 anni abbiamo
perso il 60 per cento della fauna
selvatica ed oggi ad oggi più di un
milione di specie sono a rischio di
estinzione
però c'è una buona notizia
anzi ce ne sono tre
una è che se mou riconosciamo di essere
la causa del problema possiamo giocare
un ruolo fondamentale
nel leicester nella soluzione
2 abbiamo ancora un piccolo margine di
tempo per cambiare rotta
3 abbiamo una grandissima alleata la
natura
la natura ha un potere rigenerativo
straordinario se gli lasciano gli spazi
per farlo e come possiamo farlo in mare
non possiamo fare attraverso
l'istituzione di aree marine protette
che funzionano come i parchi che abbiamo
nella terraferma quindi tutti hanno la
biodiversità ma allo stesso tempo se
sono ben gestite diventano un importante
volano di sviluppo economico e sociale
per la popolazione locale
praticamente quello che stiamo facendo
ore è usare il mare come se fosse un
conto bancario tra il quale preleviamo
preleviamo proviamo senza mai versare un
centesimo
ecco noi animali protette sono il nostro
investimento per il futuro sono il
nostro libretto di risparmio che ci
permette di salvaguardare la ricchezza e
la resilienza nel nostro mare sul lungo
termine
eppure nonostante svolgano un ruolo così
il fondamentale solo il 9 per cento del
mediterraneo è protetto e di questi siti
solo il 10 per cento a un piano di
gestione che ne garantisce l'efficacia è
troppo poco la comunità internazionale
scientifica ha parlato chiaro dobbiamo
proteggere almeno il 30 per cento
dell'oceano
entro il 2030 per salvaguardarne
funzionalità produttività e biodiversità
e credetemi che questi sono tre fattori
vitali per noi perché dalla sua
funzionalità
dipende il team è l'ossigeno che
respiriamo dalla sua produttività
dipendono la vita di miliardi di persone
sul pianeta che dipendono dal pesce come
fonte primaria di proteine ed alla
biodiversità la ricchezza della vita in
ogni sua forma
dipende il futuro del nostro pianeta
noi possiamo cambiare il mondo
però questo cambiamento parte da una
rivoluzione interiore che ci porta a
riconsiderare il nostro rapporto con la
natura che ci circonda
dobbiamo diventare nator positiv cioè
avere un impatto positivo sulla natura e
quindi andare in oltre all'uso
sostenibile delle sue risorse e iniziare
a pensare alla rigenerazione e al
ripristino degli ecosistemi
pensato a una società in cui a disegni
le attività economiche non solo
minimizzino loro entato ma
contribuiscano direttamente a migliorare
la salute del mare e credetemi che
questo non è un sogno è assolutamente
possibile soprattutto con il sapere
condiviso che abbiamo in questo momento
sapere senza veramente
precedenti
perché dove c'è volontà c'è speranza
quando è fondato l'associazione di cui
sono presidente o al rais eravamo io una
delle mie migliori amiche e mio papà e
tutti mi dicevano ma cosa fanno un
associazione che si occupa di tutela del
mare in italia non avrai futuro adesso
la nostra tv conta centinaia di persone
di artisti di media di aziende di altre
associazioni che agiscono con noi
direttamente per la salvaguardia del
mare
consapevoli che condividiamo unico ce en
e condividiamo la responsabilità di
proteggerlo
gli anni che ci aspettano sono cruciali
perché veramente noi con le nostre
decisioni e le nostre scelte
possiamo plasmare il futuro del nostro
pianeta per i secoli a venire
e quindi dobbiamo puntare in alto
dobbiamo agire uniti come umanità e dare
senso il vero e giusto senso una cosa
che forse come umanità riusciamo a fare
meglio
cambiare il mondo
partendo da qui
grazie
[Applauso]